- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par le président Mattei.
- Jean-Paul Mattei: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, chers collègues,
cette question s'adresse à vous,
madame la Première ministre.
Depuis plus d'une semaine, nous
débattons sur le projet de réforme
des retraites, essentiel pour
protéger notre système par
répartition.
Nous assistons à une forme de
dérive de notre vie politique dans
laquelle, comme un miroir
grossissant de notre société, on
peine à débattre du fond, et nous
nous arrêtons trop souvent à
l'agression de l'autre camp.
Je dois souligner que les
outrances de certains de nos
collègues ne nous engagent pas, et
on doit les dénoncer.
Par ces quelques mots, je veux
d'ailleurs remercier Olivier
Dussopt pour la compétence et la
dignité dont il fait preuve dans
ces débats.
Applaudissements
Vous le savez, les députés
démocrates sont particulièrement
sensibles au respect de la
démocratie, et la forme souvent
vient déterminer le fond.
Pour nous, l'une des origines de
ce mal est le mode de scrutin
majoritaire, qui oblige à
combattre un adversaire lors de
l'élection, attitude difficilement
réparable pendant le mandat.
Aucune véritable alliance de long
terme n'est possible, si ce n'est
des arrangements électoraux.
Au-delà de la stratégie adoptée
par certains de bloquer les débats
par des milliers d'amendements, il
nous semble urgent de mettre en
route la réforme de nos
institutions, pour remettre le
citoyen au centre du jeu
démocratique et de retrouver un
débat apaisé, où chacun a les
moyens de s'exprimer.
Pouvez-vous nous dire ce qu'il en
est du travail transpartisan sur
nos institutions?
Pourriez-vous nous donner un
calendrier ainsi que la méthode
intégrant les parlementaires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei, en
juillet dernier, dans ma
déclaration de politique générale,
j'avais affirmé la volonté du
gouvernement de répondre à la
crise démocratique que traverse
notre pays, et plus largement
notre continent.
Les raisons de cette crise sont
multiples.
Elles sont notamment
institutionnelles.
La représentativité est
essentielle à la vitalité de notre
démocratie.
Je sais que ce sujet vous tient à
coeur et qu'il importe
particulièrement à votre groupe.
Mais réfléchir à nos modes de
scrutin, c'est s'interroger plus
globalement sur le fonctionnement
de nos institutions.
Le président de la République a
lancé des consultations sur la
revitalisation de notre démocratie
et la réforme de nos institutions.
Comme il s'y était engagé, tous
les groupes parlementaires seront
associés à cette réflexion.
C'est ensemble que nous devons
construire l'avenir de nos
institutions.
Mais votre question s'inscrit dans
un contexte particulier: en
élisant une assemblée sans
majorité absolue, les Français ont
envoyé un message clair.
Ils ont demandé des compromis, des
débats fondés sur les arguments et
les idées.
Alors que votre assemblée discute
en ce moment même de notre projet
pour les retraites, un texte
important pour l'avenir de notre
pays, que voient nos compatriotes?
Un débat empêché par la
multiplication d'amendements qui
rendent impossible l'examen de la
totalité du texte, empêché par la
multiplication des injures, des
invectives et, hier même, des
accusations les plus graves,
empêché par les attaques
personnelles odieuses sans aucun
lien avec le fond du texte.
Je veux, à mon tour, redire tout
mon soutien à Olivier Dussopt.
Pensons aux Français qui nous ont
élus.
Ce débat est-il à la hauteur?
Ce débat est-il de nature à leur
faire retrouver le chemin des
urnes?
La démocratie, c'est la diversité
des opinions et le respect de
chacun.
La démocratie, c'est le refus de
l'outrance et l'attachement à la
vérité.
Je partage votre inquiétude sur la
tenue des débats et sur l'image
qu'elle donne de la démocratie.
Je veux croire qu'il n'est pas
encore trop tard pour que les
amendements de blocage soient
retirés, permettant un vrai débat
de fond.
Je veux croire qu'il n'est pas
encore trop tard pour un débat
franc, mais jamais insultant.
Je veux croire qu'il n'est pas
encore trop tard pour renoncer aux
outrances et être à la hauteur de
la mission que nous ont confiée
les Français.
Il est encore temps de montrer que
nous sommes capables de nous
opposer, parfois vivement, mais
toujours dans le respect des uns
et des autres.
Si nous y parvenons, il n'y aura
qu'une seule gagnante: la
démocratie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Thomas Ménagé.
- Thomas Ménagé: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
La semaine dernière, Gabriel Attal
a indiqué que nous étions face à
un dilemme.
Votre gouvernement entretient un
discours défaitiste, mais surtout
un discours empreint de
contrevérités pour faire peur aux
Français.
La fausse promesse d'une retraite
minimale à 1200 euros pour tous
est un exemple criant de vos
nombreux mensonges.
Depuis 2017, Emmanuel Macron
privilégie les ultrariches qui ont
gagné jusqu'à 20 fois plus que les
bas revenus, du fait de sa
politique d'injustice sociale.
Il a créé 600 milliards de dettes.
L'argent, pourtant, il y en a dans
les poches des spéculateurs dont
vous refusez de taxer les
superprofits.
Je pense à Total, qui a réalisé un
bénéfice net record de 20
milliards d'euros en 2022.
Il y en a aussi à Bercy.
Entre 2021 et 2022, les recettes
fiscales et sociales ont augmenté
de 86 milliards d'euros.
Quand les Français payent plus
cher leur carburant ou leur caddie
de course dans les supermarchés,
l'Etat s'enrichit avec de la TVA.
Vous faites le choix de ne
redistribuer que des miettes par
des chèques et des ristournes
temporaires et inefficaces.
Avec Marine Le Pen, nous avons des
solutions structurelles pour
rendre aux Français leur argent,
notamment en baissant la TVA sur
l'énergie et les carburants ou en
sortant du marché européen de
l'électricité.
Nous devons taxer les superprofits
et supprimer le minimum
vieillesse.
Tout cela demande de la volonté
politique, mais vous préférez
céder à la facilité en demandant
aux Français de travailler deux
ans de plus.
Quand allez-vous rendre aux
Français leur argent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
député Thomas Ménagé, vous seriez
plus crédible dans votre défense
du pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes si vous aviez voté
l'indemnité carburant des
travailleurs qui bénéficie à
toutes les classes moyennes de
notre pays.
Vous seriez plus crédible si vous
aviez voté le plafonnement des
prix du gaz.
Vous seriez plus crédible si vous
aviez voté le bouclier qui protège
tous les ménages les plus modestes
contre l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité.
Vous seriez plus crédible si vous
aviez lu le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui établit que la baisse
de TVA n'est pas efficace, qu'elle
ruine l'Etat et qu'elle ne
bénéficie ni aux classes moyennes
ni aux classes populaires.
Avec le président de la
République, avec tout le
gouvernement, avec cette majorité,
nous avons des résultats dont nous
sommes fiers.
Nous avons le taux d'emploi le
plus élevé depuis 50 ans dans
notre pays.
Le travail, c'est le pouvoir
d'achat, c'est de l'activité pour
tous.
Nous avons le taux de chômage le
plus bas depuis 15 ans dans notre
pays.
C'est la vraie avancée sociale.
Nous avons une croissance solide.
Que vous le vouliez ou non, nous
avons le taux d'inflation parmi
les plus faibles de la zone euro
grâce à l'action de cette majorité
et au bouclier énergétique que
vous n'avez pas voté.
Votez nos propositions, soutenez
notre action, et vous aurez les
résultats que nous avons obtenus
au service de nos compatriotes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Benjamin Lucas.
- Benjamin Lucas: Madame la
Première ministre, vous avez perdu
la bataille des retraites.
Vous l'avez perdue le 19 juin
dernier, quand les Françaises et
les Français ont refusé de donner
à Emmanuel Macron les pleins
pouvoirs.
Vous l'avez perdue dans la rue
devant un mouvement social unique
et puissant.
Vous l'avez perdue dans l'opinion
publique, comme en attestent
quotidiennement les sondages qui
nous parviennent.
Car oui, les Françaises et les
Français aspirent à travailler
mieux, à travailler moins, à
travailler tous.
Hier, on célébrait l'anniversaire
des 35 heures, mesure jadis
soutenue par Olivier Dussopt,
l'actuel ministre du Travail.
Ma question est simple: il n'est
pas trop tard pour apaiser le pays
et éviter le blocage.
Quand allez-vous renoncer à voler
aux Françaises et aux Français
deux années de vie en bonne santé?
Quand allez-vous retirer votre
réforme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député Lucas, vous nous posez des
questions, je vous en rétorque
une.
Notre système de retraite est
déficitaire.
Il le sera de 20 milliards en 2035
et de 25 milliards en 2040.
Le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites nous dit que si nous ne
faisons rien, le niveau de vie des
retraités va baisser par rapport à
la population active.
Est-ce que vous souhaitez
l'absence de retraites pour les
retraités futurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Lucas?
- Benjamin Lucas: Monsieur le
ministre, en vous entendant, je
mesure que ce qui nous oppose
n'est pas simplement une
divergence comptable, pas
seulement une opposition sociale.
C'est un véritable combat moral.
Car oui, nous considérons qu'il
est profondément immoral de voler
aux Françaises et aux Français
deux années de vie en bonne santé,
de précariser les femmes.
Vous permettez aux privilégiés
d'accumuler des richesses et de
s'accaparer les ressources.
Voilà la réalité du débat qui nous
oppose, un débat d'égalité et de
justice.
Nous entendons que vous êtes droit
dans vos bottes, comme jadis
d'autres l'étaient.
A la fin, vous retirerez cette
réforme, croyez-moi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le ministre du Travail.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous avez une
conception du combat moral qui
parfois me stupéfait.
Cela fait 10 jours que vous
déposez des amendements, pour
supprimer un alinéa technique,
pour enlever un adverbe, pour
remplacer le nom d'un index...
Autant d'amendements qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le sujet, avec
l'intérêt des Français, avec la
sauvegarde du système de retraite.
La réalité, c'est que ce qui nous
sépare, ce n'est pas une question
de moralité, mais une question de
responsabilité.
La responsabilité de préserver un
système par répartition, de
préserver un système de solidarité
intergénérationnel, de préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des Français,
la responsabilité de prendre des
décisions quand il le faut.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Michel Castellani.
- Michel Castellani: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Si l'on en croit les ambassadeurs
de l'épargne salariale, 9
milliards ont été distribués aux
salariés au titre de
l'intéressement, 8 milliards pour
la participation et 3 milliards
pour d'autres dispositifs.
En 2022, ce sont 56,5 milliards
qui ont été versés aux
actionnaires, auxquels s'ajoutent
23 milliards versés sous forme
d'actions.
Il n'en demeure pas moins que ces
données interpellent.
Elles posent une fois de plus la
question de la répartition de la
valeur ajoutée de l'entreprise,
plus largement de la richesse
nationale, entre l'économie réelle
et l'économie financière.
Ces 80 milliards soulèvent de
façon aiguë la question du
dividende aux salariés et de la
participation des travailleurs aux
bénéfices des entreprises.
Ma question est donc la suivante:
quelles mesures comptez-vous
prendre pour que les travailleurs
soient mieux rémunérés en
bénéficiant d'une part plus
consistante des bénéfices
distribués?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
député Michel Castellani, je vous
rejoins en tout point.
Il est essentiel que la France,
qui a un partage de la valeur
entre le capital et le travail qui
est stable depuis 20 ans, ce qui
est un cas unique dans les pays
développés...
Dans tous les pays développés, la
rémunération du capital est allée
plus vite que la rémunération du
travail et a créé des inégalités
et un sentiment d'injustice.
Nous voulons que cette répartition
reste équitable et nous voulons
l'améliorer au profit de ceux qui
travaillent.
Nous voulons que le partage de la
valeur soit le grand combat de
cette majorité en 2023 et dans les
années qui viennent.
Je voudrais d'abord saluer le
travail qui a été fait par les
partenaires sociaux sur ce sujet.
Ils ont obtenu, sans crier, sans
hurler, sans injurier, un accord
sur le partage de la valeur, que
je tiens à saluer et qui sera
retranscrit par voie législative
pour que tous les salariés
puissent en bénéficier.
Dès la semaine prochaine, nous
allons travailler sur la manière
de développer la participation, de
développer l'actionnariat salarié,
pour que la France reste en tête
des pays développés où le nombre
de salariés actionnaires, plus de
3 millions, est le plus important
de tous les pays développés.
Nous créons du travail, nous
créons de l'emploi.
Nous approchons du plein-emploi en
France, mais nous ne nous
satisfaisons pas de cette
réussite.
Nous voulons que le travail soit
digne, bien rémunéré, permette à
chacun de garantir sa vie.
Le partage de la valeur sera le
combat de la majorité dans les
mois qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Castellani?
- Michel Castellani: Monsieur le
ministre...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Allez-y.
- Michel Castellani: Monsieur le
ministre, je vous remercie pour
votre réponse.
Nous savons tous qu'en cette
période de difficultés sociales,
nous aurons le devoir d'améliorer
le lien social et de renforcer la
valeur travail.
Il n'est pas juste que des
personnes soient rémunérées en
millions d'euros annuels alors que
tant d'autres triment pour des
salaires qui n'excèdent que
péniblement les 1000 euros
mensuels.
C'est cette question que nous
devons traiter, sans volonté
punitive, mais dans un esprit de
solidarité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Constance Le Grip.
- Constance Le Grip: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie.
L'heure semble enfin venue pour
une politique industrielle
européenne ambitieuse.
Si nous voulons que l'Union
Européenne reste un acteur
industriel majeur, notamment dans
le secteur des industries d'avenir
et les industries vertes, nous
n'avons plus le choix: nous devons
tout mettre en oeuvre pour
atteindre l'indépendance
industrielle et la souveraineté
européenne.
Nous avons, nous Européens,
plusieurs défis à affronter: des
défis énergétiques,
environnementaux, climatiques et
économiques.
Il y a aussi le défi du
renforcement du protectionnisme
américain, notamment avec l'entrée
en vigueur prochaine du texte sur
l'inflation, l'IRA.
Face à ce plan américain massif
visant à soutenir les industries
vertes aux Etats-Unis, la riposte
européenne s'organise.
Vous avez vous-même porté, avec
votre homologue allemand, une
contribution commune proposant des
mesures fortes et sans précédent.
Vendredi dernier, le Conseil
européen des chefs d'Etat et de
gouvernement a adopté le pacte
industriel vert, préparé par la
Commission européenne et pour
lequel l'engagement de la France,
et tout particulièrement
l'investissement personnel et
constant du président Macron, a
été absolument décisif.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler les
principales mesures de la riposte
industrielle européenne?
Est-ce que le sursaut industriel
européen est là?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée Le Grip, en 2017, le
président de la République avait
appelé l'Union Européenne à un
sursaut pour défendre sa
souveraineté et son indépendance
industrielle.
Nous avons gagné une première
bataille au cours du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron, en
ouvrant la voie à la création de
nouvelles filières industrielles,
comme les batteries électriques.
C'est des milliers d'emplois qui
vont être créés dans le nord de la
France en particulier, qui vont
garantir notre indépendance en
matière de fourniture de batteries
électriques et qui vont nous
permettre d'amorcer cette
reconquête industrielle, qui est
au coeur de notre projet.
Nous venons de gagner, vendredi
dernier au Conseil européen, sous
l'impulsion d'Emmanuel Macron, une
deuxième bataille, qui est de
mettre en place un plan européen
pour l'industrie verte qui soit
capable de rivaliser avec les
décisions américaines.
Nous pourrons mettre en place les
crédits d'impôt pour soutenir
notre industrie.
Nous pourrons augmenter les
subventions.
Nous aurons une clause
d'alignement qui permettra,
lorsque les Etats-Unis proposent
un certain montant pour faire
venir une entreprise sur leur
territoire, de rivaliser avec ce
montant et de proposer exactement
le même montant pour qu'il y ait
une compétition équitable entre le
territoire américain et le
territoire européen.
Nous avons enfin décidé qu'il y
aurait une simplification massive
des projets européens pour qu'ils
aillent plus vite et qu'ils
donnent des résultats, notamment
sur le déploiement de l'hydrogène.
Il reste une troisième bataille,
que nous voulons livrer avec Agnès
Pannier-Runacher et Elisabeth
Borne, c'est la bataille du marché
européen de l'énergie.
Toutes ces décisions prises sous
l'autorité du président de la
République, qui nous ont permis
depuis six ans d'ouvrir plus
d'usines que nous en fermons, de
recréer des emplois industriels
dans un pays qui en a perdu des
centaines de milliers.
Cela suppose de découpler le prix
du gaz du prix de l'électricité
nucléaire et de payer notre
électricité nucléaire au juste
prix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Michel
Herbillon.
- Michel Herbillon: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire.
En matière de politique
économique, le gouvernement n'est
jamais avare d'éloges sur ses
résultats.
Vous venez de nous en donner une
illustration en ce début
d'après-midi.
Pourtant, nous franchissons un
niveau historique d'endettement,
et nous sommes déjà les
vice-champions du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires et des
dépenses publiques.
Et voilà qu'un nouveau record
vient de tomber, celui du déficit
commercial qui a doublé en 2022:
164 milliards d'euros, du
jamais-vu.
C'est la pire performance des pays
de l'Union Européenne.
Dans le même temps, l'Allemagne
affiche un excédent de 76
milliards d'euros, on dit que
l'Italie est en train de renouer
avec une balance commerciale
positive.
Bien sûr, une grande part de cette
dégradation s'explique par la
hausse des prix de l'énergie, mais
aussi de l'électricité.
Alors que la France exportait
jadis son électricité, nous avons
été contraints d'importer à grands
frais tant vous avez affaibli
notre parc nucléaire et notre
souveraineté énergétique.
Mais tout cela, c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt.
En 20 ans, la part de la France
dans les exportations mondiales a
diminué de moitié, de 5 à 2,5%.
La réalité, c'est l'effondrement
de notre industrie manufacturière.
Le bilan est simple: en dépit
d'efforts trop insuffisants sur
les impôts de réindustrialisation,
nos entreprises manquent encore de
compétitivité.
Votre majorité est au pouvoir
depuis six ans, et Emmanuel Macron
l'est depuis 11 ans après avoir
occupé différents postes de
ministres de secrétaires d'Etat.
Allez-vous enfin assumer de
défendre notre souveraineté
industrielle pour permettre à la
France d'être compétitive et à nos
entreprises de regagner des parts
de marché à l'étranger?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Merci.
Monsieur le député Herbillon, nous
serons d'accord sur une chose: la
balance des biens a atteint un
déficit record à 164 milliards
d'euros.
Ce n'est pas le déficit
commercial.
Le déficit commercial prend en
compte également la balance des
services et la balance des
revenus.
Or, la balance des revenus a un
excédent record de plus de 50
milliards d'euros, et la balance
des revenus, un excédent de 31
milliards.
La balance des biens s'est
dégradée.
Le déficit a doublé à cause de
l'énergie.
Notre parc nucléaire était en
partie à l'arrêt.
Cette part conjoncturelle du
déficit s'effacera d'elle-même.
Il y a en revanche, et vous avez
raison, une part structurelle du
déficit, qui est d'un côté la
désindustrialisation du pays
pendant 25 ans...
Nous sommes dans une phase de
réindustrialisation, avec plus
d'usines qui ouvrent que d'usines
qui ferment.
Nous avons des projets concrets,
comme le lithium dans l'Allier ou
dans le Bas-Rhin.
Nous avons 1222 projets qui créent
des emplois dans tous les
territoires.
Nous avons une deuxième part, qui
est la part des PME qui sont
insuffisamment exportatrices, même
si nous avons aujourd'hui plus de
144.000 entreprises exportatrices.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Emmanuel Fernandes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Dans un tweet hier en fin
d'après-midi, vous souhaitiez que
nous soyons à la hauteur des
Français qui nous ont élus et du
débat démocratique qu'ils
attendent.
Voici une occasion de prouver que
vous l'êtes.
Pouvez-vous affirmer ici que votre
projet de réforme des retraites
propose une pension minimale à
1200 euros pour tous?
Et si tel n'est pas le cas,
pouvez-vous nous dire combien de
personnes seraient concernées?
Il s'agit d'un budget rectificatif
de la Sécurité sociale.
Vous devez savoir combien de
retraités toucheraient les 1200
euros.
Publiez vos chiffres cachés!
Le 11 janvier, votre porte-parole,
Olivier Véran, déclarait que 2
millions de retraités actuels
verraient leur retraite majorée à
1200 euros brut.
Confirmez-vous ce chiffre?
Marlène Schiappa, Gabriel Attal et
d'autres, tous membres de votre
gouvernement, ont tous colporté le
même mensonge.
Oui, vous mentez.
Vous dissimulez.
La vérité, c'est celle qu'a
clairement expliquée Michaël
Zemmour: il n'y aura pas de
pension minimale garantie à 1200
euros, y compris pour les
carrières complètes.
La réalité, c'est celle décrite
par les économistes de l'institut
des politiques publiques: moins de
10% des nouveaux retraités sont
potentiellement concernés par
l'augmentation maximale de 100
euros, permettant d'approcher les
1200 euros.
Alors, cessez les mensonges.
Publiez vos chiffres cachés.
Dites-nous combien de personnes
toucheraient les 1200 euros.
Soyez à la hauteur du débat
démocratique que le pays attend.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député Fernandes, nous
allons revenir quelques mois en
arrière, pendant l'élection et la
campagne présidentielles.
Le président de la République a
dit...
Vous savez, j'ai tout mon temps.
J'ai la nuit entière pour répondre
à vos questions.
Cela fait huit jours que je vous
entends crier.
Ca ne change rien à cet instant du
débat.
Le président de la République a
pris un engagement, que nous
tenons.
Il a dit qu'il y aurait une
garantie de retraite à 85% du
SMIC.
Ce principe avait été posé en
2003.
Personne ne l'a jamais mis en
avant, nous le faisons, avec une
indexation sur le SMIC.
Combien de personnes cela va
concerner?
200.000 nouveaux retraités sur les
800.000 nouveaux retraités chaque
année.
Un retraité sur quatre aura une
pension meilleure grâce à notre
réforme.
En votant contre la réforme, vous
interdisez à un retraité sur
quatre de voir sa pension
revalorisée.
Sur les 17 millions de retraités
actuels, 1,8 million vont
bénéficier d'une revalorisation.
Là aussi, vous votez contre.
Vous refusez que des retraités
avec 900 euros aient une
revalorisation qui ira de 50 à 100
euros.
Ceux qui s'occupent des retraités
les plus modestes, c'est cette
majorité.
Ceux qui revalorisent les
retraités actuels, c'est cette
majorité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Emmanuel Fernandes: Vous ne
répondez pas.
Combien à 1200 euros par mois?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jérôme Guedj.
- Jérôme Guedj: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
à Franck Riester.
Les privilégiés n'osant plus dire
"cela est juste", ils disent
"c'est inévitable".
C'est une phrase de Jean Jaurès.
Un député qui a défendu les
retraites ouvrières, Jaurès.
C'est cette conscience collective
qui s'exprime dans le pays par le
rejet massif de la réforme des
retraites.
Les Français ne vous croient pas.
Non, votre réforme n'est pas
inévitable.
C'est un choix politique.
Pour la première fois, vous avez
décidé de ne pas mettre à
contribution les entreprises, mais
de faire porter l'effort sur les
salariés.
Nous avons une palette de
solutions à vous proposer, nous
pouvons supprimer les niches
sociales, jugées inefficaces.
Vous allez nous répondre que nous
taxons.
Mais c'est pour faire oublier
votre obsession, qui est
d'exonérer!
Nous vous disons de partager.
Entendez le gouverneur de la
Banque de France qui exhorte à ce
que l'on arrête la course à la
baisse d'impôts, au nom de la
solidarité!
Dans quelques années, il y aura un
excédent de l'assurance-chômage et
un déficit équivalent de
l'assurance retraite.
Vous ne pensez pas que cela peut
se compenser?
Votre autre postulat, c'est de
faire travailler plus pour
produire plus, mais que
faites-vous de ces retraités qui
participent à la vie sociale du
pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Je crois que
nous aurons l'occasion dans
quelques heures de terminer
l'examen de l'article 2 du projet
de loi, et d'ouvrir la discussion
sur un certain nombre
d'amendements.
A y regarder de plus près, que
proposez-vous?
Nous avons un déficit qui est
structurel.
Nous avons un déficit qui arrive
pour 2030, puis 2040.
Si nous ne faisons rien, nous
allons accumuler le déficit.
Vous nous dites de taxer des
superprofits.
Vous pensez que la recette
exceptionnelle d'une année reste
la solution à la dépense
structurelle d'une décennie.
Ce n'est pas sérieux.
Vous nous reprochez de vouloir
financer le système de retraites
par le recours au travail, mais
admettez avec moi que nous sommes
peut-être allés à bonne école.
L'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation de 40 à 42 annuités,
qui l'a votée?
C'est nous, sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande.
Vous ne l'avez peut-être pas voté,
car vous étiez déjà dans le camp
de la fronde.
Ceux qui ont connu la fronde, ils
savent qu'il n'y a rien de pire
que de fracturer une majorité.
Je vais en terminer maintenant.
Vous avez ouvert votre question
par une citation de Jean Jaurès,
mais vous n'en avez pas été digne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
maintenant à madame Laurence
Heydel Grillere.
- Laurence Heydel Grillere: Ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale.
Monsieur le ministre, au moment où
la nouvelle carte scolaire est
publiée, la question du comptage
des effectifs est un sujet majeur.
Dans ma circonscription, en
Ardèche, je peux citer l'exemple
de deux communes où des postes
vont être supprimés, car
l'Académie a jugé que les petites
sections ne rentraient pas dans le
comptage des effectifs globaux.
Cela, au motif qu'elles ne sont
pas situées en zone de montagne.
Pourtant, elles sont bien en zone
rurale.
Votre ministère avait tranché la
question.
Cette situation déstabilise
grandement nos communes rurales.
Combien de temps faudra-t-il
encore pour trancher sur le
comptage des effectifs?
Combien d'enseignants, combien de
maires faudra-t-il encore rassurer
chaque année?
Nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
fragiliser ainsi nos territoires
ruraux.
Nous devons encourager les
partenariats avec des acteurs
locaux.
L'avenir de notre jeunesse est
primordial.
Donnons aux enfants des
territoires ruraux les mêmes
chances que celles de tous les
autres enfants.
C'est le combat de notre majorité.
C'est pourquoi je vous demande
quelles sont les actions que vous
allez mettre en place pour
réaffirmer des directives du
ministère sur le comptage des
petites sections?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye, ministre de
l'Education nationale.
- Pap Ndiaye: Votre question
s'inscrit évidemment dans le
contexte général d'une baisse des
effectifs scolaires.
C'est vrai à l'échelle nationale
et c'est vrai également dans votre
département de l'Ardèche, qui
comptera 239 élèves en moins dans
le premier degré à la rentrée
2023.
Sur votre question de la prise en
compte des enfants de moins de 3
ans dans l'élaboration de la carte
scolaire, la politique du
ministère n'a pas changé.
Les enfants de moins de 3 ans
peuvent être accueillis en école
maternelle dans le cadre des très
petites sections.
C'est particulièrement vrai en
zone d'éducation prioritaire et
dans les territoires ruraux.
Nous ne prenons en compte les
enfants de moins de 3 ans que dans
le cadre de leur scolarisation.
Nous ne prenons pas en compte
l'ensemble des enfants de moins de
3 ans pour élaborer la carte
scolaire.
Cela se fait en prenant en compte
l'effectivité de la scolarisation
des enfants de moins de 3 ans.
Nous ne nous appuyons pas sur un
recensement général, mais sur la
prise en compte des très petites
sections des écoles maternelles.
Le travail est en train de se
faire avec les élus locaux et les
directions académiques pour ouvrir
et fermer des classes en fonction
des réalités locales.
Nous allons procéder, d'ici au
mois de juin, aux ajustements
nécessaires en fonction des
réalités locales et en fonction
des échanges avec les élus locaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Xavier Breton.
- Xavier Breton: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
la Culture.
Madame la ministre, de très
nombreuses personnes ont été
choquées par les menaces que vous
avez formulées à l'encontre des
chaînes C8 et CNews.
En menaçant ces chaînes de ne pas
renouveler leur fréquence, vous
avez heurté les téléspectateurs
qui y trouvaient d'autres façons
de s'informer.
Vous avez également touché ceux
qui sont attachés au pluralisme de
l'information.
Dans une démocratie, sur un sujet
aussi sensible que l'information,
un gouvernement se doit d'observer
une stricte réserve.
Il ne peut pas prendre parti.
C'est pourtant ce que vous avez
fait.
En le faisant, non seulement, vous
avez menacé la liberté
d'expression, mais vous avez remis
en cause l'indépendance de
l'Arcom.
Normalement, elle devrait être une
autorité publique indépendante.
Avec vos propos, vous discréditez
son impartialité.
Allez-vous observer à l'avenir une
plus stricte neutralité pour
respecter le pluralisme de
l'information?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Rima
Abdul-Malak, ministre de la
Culture.
- Rima Abdul-Malak: Soit vous
n'avez pas écouté mon interview,
soit vous tenez absolument à
déformer mes propos, peut-être
pour détourner le regard des
faits.
La loi de 1986 est une loi
importante qui prévoit des
obligations pour les chaînes qui
ont des fréquences gratuites.
Si ces chaînes ne respectent pas
les obligations, elles s'exposent
à des sanctions.
C'est à l'autorité régulatrice de
prononcer ces sanctions.
Quelles sont ces obligations?
Elles s'appliquent à toutes les
chaînes.
Il faut les rappeler.
Traiter des affaires judiciaires
avec mesure, assurer l'expression
des différents points de vue sur
les sujets qui prêtent à
controverse, respecter
l'indépendance de l'information,
notamment à l'égard des intérêts
économiques des actionnaires ou
des annonceurs, etc.
Quel est le constat aujourd'hui?
Prenons les interventions de
l'Arcom, elles sont publiques.
Depuis 2019, deux interventions
pour France Télévisions, aucune
pour TF1, aucune pour M6 et une
vingtaine pour les deux chaînes
que vous avez mentionnées.
Il n'a jamais été question
d'interdire telle ou telle chaîne.
Nous ne souhaitons pas nous
immiscer dans les pouvoirs du
régulateur, qui est indépendant.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Mon cher
collègue?
- Xavier Breton: Votre meilleure
réponse aurait été de prendre acte
et de dire qu'il y a bien une
stricte neutralité qui s'impose
pour les ministres.
Plus vous parlez, plus vous vous
enfoncez.
Vous rappelez un cadre légal, mais
ensuite, vous menacez.
Il faut faire attention.
S'il y a des chaînes de télévision
qui ne correspondent pas à la
pensée unique ou à la bien-pensance
que vous voulez imposer, il y a
une réaction.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, cher collègue.
La parole est à madame Emeline
K/Bidi.
- Emeline K/Bidi: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail.
Pour tenter de diluer l'injustice
de votre réforme, vous avez
annoncé aux Français sur les
plateaux télé qu'ils pourraient
bénéficier à minima d'une retraite
à 1200 euros.
Les Français ne sont pas dupes.
Ils se massent dans la rue.
Vous revenez sur vos promesses.
On se surprend à lire les
conditions écrites tout en bas du
contrat que vous entendez nous
faire signer.
Vous affirmez qu'il faudra avoir
travaillé 43 ans en ayant été payé
au SMIC pour avoir la pension à
1200 euros.
Combien de personnes pourront
véritablement prétendre à cette
pension à 1200 euros?
Vous refusez de répondre
précisément.
Un autre mensonge que vous avez
formulé concerne les travailleurs
les plus pauvres.
Ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
ils se verraient imposer deux
années de plus pour une retraite
tout aussi misérable.
Je pense aux auxiliaires de vie,
aux saisonniers agricoles...
Parmi ceux-là, je pense
particulièrement à mes
compatriotes d'outre-mer.
Ils souffrent souvent de temps
partiel subi, de revenus en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté, mais
aussi parce qu'il leur a fallu
attendre presque un demi-siècle
pour aligner leur SMIC sur celui
de l'Hexagone.
Pouvez-vous nous dire combien de
personnes ne bénéficieront pas de
cette pension minimum?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le ministre du Travail.
- Olivier Dussopt: Je risque de
répéter certains arguments, vous
me pardonnerez.
Le président de la République l'a
dit, l'engagement de 85% du SMIC,
c'est pour une carrière complète
au niveau du SMIC.
Nous poursuivons cet objectif de
garantir un minimum de pension.
Vous me demandez combien de
personnes cela représente.
Un retraité sur quatre bénéficiera
d'une revalorisation de pension.
Sur les 1,8 million de retraités
actuels, il va y avoir une
revalorisation...
Chahut
...
Je tiens à apporter une réponse
précise à la question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Est-ce que
vous pouvez écouter la réponse du
ministre?
Merci, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Paul
Christophe.
- Paul Christophe: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre des
Solidarités.
Nous arrivons à la Journée
mondiale des cancers de l'enfant.
Chaque année, 2800 enfants et
adolescents sont concernés par un
cancer.
C'est l'affaire de tous et cela
doit nous réunir pour renforcer le
soin pédiatrique et la prévention.
Nous devons augmenter les moyens
que nous mettons à disposition des
familles pour surmonter le choc
que représente un cancer chez un
enfant.
Les services pédiatriques font
partie intégrante des plans
gouvernementaux.
La nouvelle stratégie comprend
désormais un volet de prise en
charge des enfants malades et de
leur famille.
Nous avons progressé ces dernières
années.
De nombreux dispositifs ont été
créés ou améliorés.
Notamment, le doublement du congé
de présence parentale.
Nous saluons aussi l'initiative
récente qui propose une nouvelle
garantie d'aide à la famille,
construite avec la fédération
Grandir sans cancer.
Je profite également de l'occasion
pour saluer l'ensemble des
associations qui
accompagnent les familles
concernées.
Les besoins des familles sont
encore aujourd'hui nombreux.
La nature exceptionnelle, brutale
et urgente de la situation doit
donc nous amener à prendre des
mesures exceptionnelles et
réellement adaptées.
A la veille de cette Journée
mondiale, pourriez-vous nous
indiquer comment nous pourrions
collectivement aller plus loin
pour mieux accompagner les
familles dans cette épreuve?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci
pour votre question.
Vous rappelez des chiffres qui
doivent nous interpeller.
Derrière les chiffres, il y a des
familles qui vivent des situations
douloureuses.
Il y a des enfants qui souffrent.
Il y a des parents qui voient leur
quotidien bouleversé.
Il y a des frères et des soeurs
auxquels il faut penser.
Nous devons tous mettre en place
un accompagnement qui soit le plus
adapté possible à ces situations.
Demain, vous l'avez dit, ce sera
la Journée internationale des
cancers de l'enfant.
C'est l'occasion de rappeler tout
ce que nous avons fait en la
matière.
Ces dernières années, il y a eu de
nombreuses avancées.
Beaucoup ont été votées dans cet
hémicycle.
Je pense notamment à la loi du 15
novembre 2021 qui a permis
d'améliorer les conditions de
présence parentale auprès des
enfants.
Je souhaite que nous allions
aujourd'hui plus loin.
La proposition de loi que vous
portez va nous y aider.
Nous allons pouvoir fluidifier les
parcours des familles et mieux les
protéger des aléas financiers.
Nous pouvons y réfléchir au
travers de nouvelles stratégies.
Avec mon collègue François Braun,
nous maintenons un engagement
total auprès des familles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur René Pilato.
- René Pilato: Ma question
s'adresse à la Première ministre.
Il y a maintenant 15 jours, une
législative partielle s'est tenue
dans les Charentes.
Face à la candidature d'un
candidat de votre majorité, j'ai
proposé aux électeurs de répondre
à un référendum sur la mise en
place de la réforme des retraites.
Je vous apporte désormais la
réponse: c'est non.
Les manifestants sont calmes,
déterminés et dignes.
Leur colère est prête à exploser.
Loin de s'affaiblir, le mouvement
s'amplifie.
Vous avez perdu la bataille de
l'opinion.
Les huit centrales de
l'intersyndicale sont prêtes à
mettre la France à l'arrêt dès le
7 mars.
Ici, dans cette Assemblée, vous
avez contre vous le temps de débat
afin de ne pas discuter du fond, à
savoir le partage des richesses.
Vous vous targuez de ce que les
riches placent leur argent en
France.
On peut les comprendre.
Avec l'aide de votre gouvernement,
vous leur permettez de se gaver
comme jamais.
Cette réforme va les gaver
davantage.
Cela se sait.
Pendant ce temps, le prix des
aliments a explosé.
Le prix de l'énergie a explosé.
Les pauvres sont de plus en plus
pauvres.
Les indicateurs sont tous au
rouge.
Par votre entêtement, prenez-vous
le risque de provoquer une
explosion sociale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le ministre du Travail.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, permettez-moi avant de
commencer de vous adresser mes
félicitations républicaines pour
votre élection.
Permettez-moi aussi, par ce même
message, de dire à celui à qui
vous succédez l'amitié qui est la
nôtre et la reconnaissance de ses
collègues pour le travail qu'il a
fait ici.
Vous dites qu'une élection
législative partielle est un
référendum, je crois que ce n'est
pas à la hauteur.
Nous avons une responsabilité,
c'est celle de garantir la
pérennité du système de retraites
par répartition.
Nous avons une responsabilité qui
reste de garantir le niveau des
pensions pour les retraités.
Ce que nous voulons faire avec
cette réforme, c'est cela.
Nous voulons équilibrer un système
et l'améliorer pour mieux tenir
compte des carrières longues, des
métiers pénibles, mais aussi en
revalorisant les petites
retraites.
Monsieur le député, vous avez fait
un parallèle qui vous appartient
entre la réforme des retraites et
des questions relatives au pouvoir
d'achat.
Maintenant que vous êtes là, je
vous demande d'associer vos votes
aux initiatives de la majorité
quand il s'agit de faire un chèque
pour aider les ménages pour
l'achat de carburant.
Je vous demande d'associer vos
votes à la majorité pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Nous avons une chance incroyable.
Nous sommes dans le pays qui
résiste le mieux à l'inflation.
Nous sommes le pays qui crée
encore de l'emploi, malgré la
crise.
Nous le faisons malgré
l'opposition résolue de ceux qui
vous entourent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Philippe Guillemard.
En février dernier, un dispositif
a
donné lieu à plusieurs débats.
Jusqu'ici, la conduite du régime
nous conduit vers une hypothèse.
Les condamnations à mort sont des
atteintes graves aux droits
fondamentaux.
Beaucoup ont choisi de se
mobiliser contre le sort réservé
aux manifestants en parrainant les
Iraniens qui ont été condamnés à
mort.
Beaucoup sont détenus en Iran de
façon arbitraire.
A cet égard, nous nous réjouissons
de la libération d'une chercheuse
franco-iranienne après quatre ans
de détention.
Madame la ministre, près de 5 mois
après le début de cette
mobilisation inédite de la
population, quelles sont les
mesures à prendre face aux actes
de ce régime qui tue sa
population?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna,
ministre des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Monsieur le
député, madame la présidente,
notre action concernant l'Iran
vise à concilier deux exigences.
Faire face à la répression par
l'Iran de sa propre population,
une population qui ne demande qu'à
vivre libre, protéger nos
ressortissants qui sont
injustement détenus par un régime
qui cherche des coupables
extérieurs à ses propres échecs.
Concrètement, notre réponse à la
répression en Iran prend deux
formes.
Premièrement, elle vise le régime
qui exerce la répression.
Nous avons obtenu l'exclusion de
l'Iran de la commission des
Nations Unies sur les droits de la
femme.
Nous avons obtenu par l'ONU une
mission d'établissement des faits
qui permettra de documenter la
répression.
Deuxièmement, notre réponse vise
aussi les responsables.
Nous avons pris aussi quatre
trains de mesures européennes.
Un autre train de mesures sera
probablement adopté très
prochainement par les ministres
des Affaires étrangères de l'Union
Européenne.
Cependant, nous continuons à
dialoguer avec l'Iran pour
demander la libération de tous nos
otages.
Pour la première fois, les
conclusions européennes du 23
janvier dernier demandent des
comptes sur la politique de
détention arbitraire de l'Iran.
Il s'agit bien d'une politique
d'Etat.
Notre priorité reste la libération
de tous nos compatriotes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
maintenant à monsieur Charles de
Courson.
- Charles de Courson: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Ma question porte sur la situation
très particulière du président de
la République au regard des droits
à la retraite.
Le président de la République
n'est affilié à aucun des 42
régimes de retraite existants.
Cette situation n'est pas
satisfaisante.
Lors du débat sur le projet de loi
sur les retraites en 2020, j'avais
coécrit un texte pour affilier le
président de la République au
régime universel dans une
perspective d'exemplarité.
Le rapporteur de ce texte,
monsieur Olivier Véran, avait
alors déclaré: "Vous avez
parfaitement raison,
mais le chef de l'Etat s'est
engagé à prendre un décret visant
à intégrer les régimes de retraite
des présidents de la République
dans le régime universel."
Nous pouvons faire confiance au
président.
Le secrétaire d'Etat, Laurent
Pietraszewski, appuyait les propos
du rapporteur en déclarant: "Le
but est de montrer l'exemple.
Nous souhaitons que l'exemple
vienne d'en haut."
C'est ce que fera le président de
la République.
Trois années plus tard, ce décret
n'a toujours pas été publié.
Ainsi, ma question est simple: le
gouvernement envisage-t-il
toujours de publier un décret
affiliant le président de la
République au régime général?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député de Courson, nous examinons
actuellement un texte sur la
réforme des retraites qui concerne
chacun des 42 régimes, mais vous
savez, tout comme moi, qu'il
existe un certain nombre de
régimes particuliers, qui sont
parfois régis par des décisions
relevant du bureau des assemblées,
qui relèvent de décisions du
bureau des assemblées.
Il existe des régimes de retraite
qui relèvent de loi organique,
c'est le cas des membres du
Conseil constitutionnel.
Il existe des régimes qui ne sont
pas des régimes de retraite, qui
sont des régimes de pension, des
régimes prévus par la République
pour assurer une indemnité
minimale et une forme d'allocation
à l'ancien président de la
République définie par le décret
que vous avez rappelé.
Ce n'est pas un décret que le
gouvernement doit prendre.
Il relève du seul président de la
République.
Si nous ne sommes plus dans une
logique de création d'un système
universel, le président de la
République a la possibilité de
dire combien, en la matière, pour
la période qui viendra d'ici la
fin de son mandat, il doit être
exemplaire.
Il a toujours été au rendez-vous
de ses engagements.
- Charles de Courson: Monsieur le
ministre, j'ai parlé
d'exemplarité.
Vous me répondez qu'il y a
d'autres régimes particuliers que
le régime du président de la
République, dont le régime des
parlementaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Véronique
Louwagie.
- Véronique Louwagie: La question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Les Républicains sont attachés au
système de retraite par
répartition voulu par le général
de Gaulle et fondé sur le principe
de la solidarité entre les
générations.
Un régime qui a été par ailleurs
préservé par différentes réformes
précédentes.
A ce jour, la démographie menace
l'équilibre du système, une
réforme est donc nécessaire.
Elle est même devenue urgente.
Le président de la République
refusant la baisse des pensions
comme la hausse des cotisations,
les députés Les Républicains ont
obtenu le renoncement à relever
l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans.
Mais il y a encore des avancées
nécessaires.
Nous voulons que cette réforme
soit un véritable instrument de
redistribution à destination des
mères de famille qui ont eu des
carrières hachées, par exemple.
Mais ma question porte sur une
meilleure prise en compte de la
spécificité des carrières longues
pour que personne ne pâtisse de la
réforme.
En relevant l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite à 64 ans, il est
impératif qu'une attention encore
plus importante soit apportée à
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt.
Ma question est simple: madame la
Première ministre, pouvez-vous
assurer qu'aucune des personnes
engagées dans une carrière longue
définie par la réforme Fillon de
2003 ne travaillera plus de 43
ans?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
députée Louwagie, vous
m'interrogez sur un point
essentiel de notre projet pour les
retraites.
Comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire dès le 10 janvier, lors de la
présentation de la réforme, la
prise en compte de la situation de
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt est un des
marqueurs forts de ce projet.
Beaucoup de choses ont été dites
ou écrites sur ce sujet, y compris
des inexactitudes ou des
contrevérités.
Je veux donc être la plus claire
possible.
Je voudrais le souligner, si nous
sommes attentifs à garder la
cohérence globale de notre projet,
à la différence de certains dans
cet hémicycle qui font obstacle au
débat, le gouvernement a écouté et
fait évoluer son projet en
fonction des arguments et des
propositions défendues par les uns
et les autres.
La cohérence exige d'abord de
rappeler que notre système de
retraite repose sur le respect
d'une double condition d'âge de
départ et de durée de cotisation
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une
pension.
Le dispositif dit de carrière
longue répond, quant à lui, à ces
mêmes règles, en y ajoutant la
condition d'avoir travaillé quatre
ou cinq trimestres avant un
certain âge.
Nous ne touchons pas à ces
principes.
Pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler le plus tôt, nous
améliorons même leur situation.
J'ai eu l'occasion de l'indiquer
il y a une dizaine de jours, nous
allons étendre ce dispositif à
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
entre 20 et 21 ans, avec une durée
de cotisation précise, un âge
anticipé de départ à 63 ans, et la
nécessité d'avoir travaillé quatre
ou cinq trimestres avant la fin de
l'année civile de ses 21 ans.
Pourquoi avons-nous bougé sur ce
point?
Les 20-21 ans devaient atteindre
l'âge légal prévu à l'article 7 du
projet de loi.
J'ai pris un engagement, et il
donne lieu à un amendement du
gouvernement déposé aujourd'hui
pour cette tranche d'âge.
Ce sera donc aussi le cas pour les
personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler à 17 ans et dont l'âge
de départ anticipé est fixé à 60
ans.
Je suis attachée aux principes des
carrières longues qui ont été
fixées à l'époque dans une réforme
portée par François Fillon.
Je suis attachée plus globalement
aux règles de notre système de
retraite fondées sur un double
critère d'âge de départ et de
durée de cotisation.
Je suis attachée par-dessus tout à
la viabilité de notre système de
retraite par répartition, et c'est
précisément pour ça que je pense
qu'il est indispensable d'en
assurer l'équilibre.
Je mesure ce que cela représente
pour chacun de nos concitoyens,
pour chaque Français dans sa vie
quotidienne.
Le débat parlementaire est
précieux pour éclairer ces enjeux,
et le travail qui sera fait sur
ces décrets sera conduit dans la
transparence.
Dans une réforme comme celle-ci,
des points qui peuvent paraître
techniques ne sont pas
secondaires, et les
simplifications sont rapidement
mensongères.
J'assume que mon gouvernement et
moi-même avons toujours des
expressions précises, sans doute
trop peu lyriques au goût de
certains, pour parler de cette
réforme.
C'est la condition de la vérité,
et je n'y dérogerai pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame
Louwagie?
- Véronique Louwagie: Merci pour
ces réponses.
Nous sommes tous attachés à avoir
un mixte du relèvement de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite et
d'une prise en compte de la durée
de cotisation.
Il nous faut prendre en compte
que, le plus souvent, les métiers
qui sont débutés tôt sont des
métiers qui sont physiquement
exposés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Lisette Pollet.
- Lisette Pollet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre du Travail et du Plein
Emploi.
S'occuper d'un parent invalide ou
d'un enfant handicapé à domicile a
généralement des conséquences
importantes sur la carrière.
En 2021, un Français sur six a un
proche malade, âgé ou handicapé.
Depuis 2014, les proches
bénéficient d'un trimestre de
majoration par période de 30 mois
dans la limite de huit trimestres.
La solidarité nationale ne relaye
pas encore suffisamment la
solidarité familiale.
Dans le contexte actuel de pénurie
de professionnels, de nombreux
proches n'ont pas de meilleure
solution.
Votre réforme ne parvient pas à
prendre en compte la réalité de la
situation des aidants.
Ils sont exposés à l'usure.
C'est le cas de plusieurs parents
dans la Drôme qui doivent aménager
leur temps de travail pour
s'occuper de leurs proches.
Il est indispensable de
reconnaître les efforts qu'ils
fournissent.
Qu'attendez-vous pour reconnaître
l'investissement de tous ces
aidants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, l'essentiel des réponses
à votre question est à l'article
12 du projet de loi.
J'espère que nous aurons
l'occasion de l'examiner, mais cet
article 12 a plusieurs objectifs
et plusieurs mérites.
D'abord, pour mieux accompagner
les aidants et faire en sorte que
les périodes de vie consacrées à
accompagner un proche malade,
handicapé ou en fin de vie, soient
des périodes qui soient mieux
protégées.
Nous allons créer aussi un
dispositif spécifique qui va
permettre de rassembler plusieurs
dispositions un peu éparses.
Nous allons aussi accorder des
droits à davantage d'aidants,
notamment les aidants d'enfants en
situation de handicap.
Nous créerons un minimum
vieillesse, une assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants.
Ces trimestres vont pouvoir être
validés et intégrés dans la durée
de cotisation requise pour avoir
droit à une retraite sans décote.
Nous devons peut-être aller plus
loin, mais nous commencerons à
quatre trimestres.
Notre objectif n'est pas
anecdotique.
Il est de faire en sorte qu'avec
ce système d'assurance pour les
aidants, nous puissions
accompagner 100.000 personnes par
an, qui vont pouvoir ainsi voir
des trimestres validés et voir
leur engagement être non pas
récompensé, mais reconnu et
parfois compensé.
Il y aura très certainement des
débats à l'article 12, mais je
crois qu'avec ce texte, nous
allons très largement dans la
direction que vous appelez de vos
voeux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Yannick Haury.
- Yannick Haury: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre des
Transports.
L'attractivité
des transports publics au
quotidien dépend essentiellement
du service rendu en matière de
sécurité, de fiabilité, de respect
des horaires et aussi de propreté,
d'information des voyageurs, de
synchronisation des
correspondances.
La loi d'orientation des mobilités
portée par madame la Première
ministre a permis d'investir
davantage dans les transports au
quotidien.
Les titres de transport se
multiplient, obligeant parfois les
usagers à jongler entre plusieurs
abonnements et services.
Dans ma circonscription, les
tarifications sont diverses et
spécifiques.
Cette diversité nuit à
l'attractivité des solutions de
mobilité collective proposées.
La mise en place d'un ticket
unique à l'échelle nationale se
développe dans plusieurs pays
européens.
Ce système fonctionnant à grande
échelle facilite le quotidien des
usagers car il simplifie et donc
encourage l'accès aux transports
en commun.
Vous avez annoncé vouloir
développer un titre unique de
transport pour toute la France et
avez lancé pour cela
un dispositif spécifique.
Avec quel financement et sous
quelle forme pourrait se
concrétiser ce titre unique de
transport?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Monsieur le
député Haury, merci de mettre
l'accent sur cette question très
importante du fonctionnement de
nos transports publics.
Quand nous parlons de mobilité,
nous parlons souvent de grands
projets d'investissements et
d'infrastructures.
Sous l'autorité du député David
Valence, le Conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures a préparé un
rapport sur les investissements.
Nous devons aussi avoir une
attention particulière, et c'est
parfois un changement culturel
pour l'Etat, sur les petites
choses du quotidien qui sont
souvent négligées: l'information,
la propreté, la sécurité,
l'accessibilité de nos transports
publics.
La loi d'orientation des
mobilités, qui était très
importante à cet égard, a permis
des avancées dans ce domaine, mais
nous devons sans doute aller plus
loin.
C'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
proposé de lancer un chantier sur
un titre unique de transport.
Je l'ai fait de manière
partenariale, en proposant à des
associations de collectivités de
lancer ce travail ensemble il y a
quelques jours.
Je l'ai fait en ayant aussi le
souci de l'innovation française et
de nos jeunes entreprises.
C'est dans cet esprit que nous
avons organisé un premier forum de
l'innovation dans les transports
la semaine dernière, avec
plusieurs milliers de
participants.
Nous avons sélectionné d'ores et
déjà collectivement, avec les
associations d'élus, deux
solutions françaises collectives
associant tous ces acteurs, pour
que, d'ici la fin de l'année, nous
ayons des propositions précises
qui ne mettent personne de côté,
des solutions numériques, mais
aussi les solutions papier, pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'exclusion en
la matière.
Nous avons tous les atouts pour
réussir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Loïc Prud'homme.
- Loïc Prud'homme: Merci.
Messieurs les ministres de
l'Agriculture et de l'Intérieur,
pollution persistante de l'eau, de
l'air et des sols, impact sur la
biodiversité, disparition de 80%
de populations d'insectes
entrants...
C'est notre environnement, un
bilan documenté dans un rapport
scientifique commun.
Certains dénoncent l'accaparement
de la ressource en eau.
Vous, vous inventez une cellule de
gendarmerie.
Vous mobilisez des milliers de
gendarmes, des caméras de
surveillance, des traceurs GPS,
des écoutes téléphoniques, des
comparutions immédiates.
La question est simple.
Allez-vous mobiliser les mêmes
moyens pour remettre à la justice
les trois personnes qui ont
lâchement agressé l'agriculteur
Paul François, à qui j'adresse
tout mon soutien au nom de mon
groupe?
Paul François est cet agriculteur
qui, après 15 ans de procédures, a
fait condamner Bayer Monsanto pour
intoxication.
Il a été ligoté et obligé à boire
une substance inconnue par trois
personnes qui l'ont menacé et
violenté.
Messieurs les ministres, combien
de temps pour une réaction de
votre part?
L'impunité de cette agression ne
doit pas être une option
envisageable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture, on ne peut que
condamner les violences contre cet
agriculteur qui a été victime
d'une agression le 30 janvier
dernier à son domicile.
Il a été ligoté par un ou
plusieurs individus, et il a été
fortement menacé.
La justice a été saisie de
l'enquête.
Elle a été confiée à la brigade de
recherche sous l'autorité du
parquet d'Angoulême.
On pourrait imaginer, même si
l'enquête judiciaire ne l'a pas
conclu, que ce serait en lien avec
ses prises de position publiques
contre la firme Monsanto, qu'il a
fait condamner après avoir été
intoxiqué par un herbicide.
Il est évident que le gouvernement
condamne cette agression.
Il appartient à l'autorité
judiciaire de mener des enquêtes
et de saisir les moyens de police
et de gendarmerie qu'elle
souhaite.
Les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur sont à la disposition
de la justice.
Les patrouilles autour de son
domicile ont été accentuées.
Son domicile et sa ferme ont été
gardés par les services du
ministère de l'Intérieur.
Tout agriculteur qui se fait
agresser, quelle qu'en soit la
cause, est protégé par les
services du ministère de
l'Intérieur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Prud'homme?
- Loïc Prud'homme: Vous avez mis
moins de trois heures pour traiter
des manifestants d'écoterroristes.
Combien de temps mettrez-vous pour
traiter de "phyto-terroristes" ces
personnes pro-Monsanto prêtes à
tout?
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous n'empêchez
pas la polémique.
Peut-être auriez-vous vu une
différence entre l'ordre public et
les enquêtes qui relèvent du
ministre de la Justice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à François Jolivet.
- François Jolivet: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
du Travail.
L'INSEE nous apprend aujourd'hui
une bonne nouvelle: le taux de
chômage du quatrième trimestre
2022 a enregistré encore une
baisse.
Il est de 7,2% de la population
active.
C'est le plus bas niveau depuis 40
ans.
Nous pouvons nous en réjouir,
quels que soient les bancs sur
lesquels nous siégeons.
Comme quoi, la courbe du chômage
peut s'inverser, même après une
crise Covid.
C'est aussi une bonne nouvelle
pour le financement de nos
retraites.
Cette nouvelle baisse du chômage
est donc la preuve que notre
économie résiste, en raison des
employeurs, publics ou privés,
mais c'est aussi sans doute la
preuve que la politique de
l'emploi que nous menons depuis
2017 commence à porter ses fruits.
Le groupe Horizons est
profondément attaché à la valeur
travail.
Nous sommes convaincus que le
travail est la garantie pour
chacune et chacun de trouver sa
place dans la société.
Travailler, c'est d'abord être
libre.
Nous devons poursuivre cet effort
important, notamment envers les
personnes les plus éloignées du
travail.
Notre objectif est bien de
parvenir au plein-emploi d'ici la
fin du quinquennat.
Pourriez-vous nous dire quels sont
vos prochains chantiers pour
atteindre cet objectif?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre du Travail.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous avez
raison, l'INSEE a livré une bonne
nouvelle ce matin.
Au quatrième trimestre de l'année
2022, le taux de chômage est passé
de 7,2 à 7,3.
C'est le plus bas taux depuis 40
ans.
Cela se traduit par une baisse du
taux de chômage des moins de 25
ans de 1 point.
Cela se conjugue à d'autres bonnes
nouvelles.
Le taux d'activité des Français
âgés de 15 à 64 ans n'a jamais été
aussi élevé.
Il y a aussi une autre bonne
nouvelle, c'est que les emplois
qui ont été créés au cours du
deuxième semestre 2022 sont des
contrats de plus d'un mois des
CDI, pour 52% d'entre eux.
Pour poursuivre sur cette
tendance, il y a trois chantiers.
Le premier, c'est de garantir
l'emploi pour tous.
Personne n'est inemployable.
Il faut mieux accompagner les
allocataires du RSA dans la
formation.
Il faut aider les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi.
Nous allons aussi travailler sur
les conditions de travail.
J'étais ce matin devant le Conseil
économique et social pour en
parler.
Le travail doit être un outil
d'émancipation, mais aussi un
univers d'épanouissement, dans
lequel on se sent utile
socialement.
Troisième chantier majeur, pour
donner du sens au travail, il faut
le partage de la valeur.
Aujourd'hui, un accord a été
trouvé.
Il est en cours de signature.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Yannick Monnet.
- Yannick Monnet: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Nous avons appris avec stupeur
l'ampleur des suppressions de
postes prévues pour la carte
scolaire 2023.
Sur le territoire national, ce
n'est pas moins de 1117 postes du
premier degré que vous prévoyez de
supprimer, à peine compensés par
les 450 postes d'enseignants
stagiaires, ce qui conduit à 667
suppressions de postes pour la
rentrée 2023.
Ces suppressions se font souvent
sans concertation avec les élus
locaux.
Dans mon département de l'Allier,
29 suppressions.
En Seine-Saint-Denis, sur la seule
ville de Saint-Denis, ce sont 22
suppressions.
Les conséquences de ce
désengagement de l'Etat sont
désastreuses pour les familles,
pour les enfants, pour la
communauté éducative, tout comme
pour l'éducation prioritaire.
C'est un choix purement politique
que de contraindre les moyens
dédiés à l'enseignement, alors que
dans le même temps, vous n'hésitez
pas à augmenter le budget de
l'armée.
Nos campagnes et nos quartiers ont
déjà connu le départ de temps de
service public.
Votre rôle n'est pas d'organiser
le déclin de certains territoires,
mais de garantir leur
attractivité.
Ces fermetures sonnent comme une
trahison faite aux élus locaux et
aux communes, que vous étiez bien
content de trouver pour gérer la
crise Covid.
C'est aussi un gaspillage
considérable d'argent public,
puisque bon nombre de ces
fermetures interviennent après des
investissements de réhabilitation
d'écoles financées par les
collectivités et l'Etat lui-même.
La baisse du nombre d'enfants ne
peut justifier cette gabegie.
La France est le pays de l'Union
Européenne où il y a le plus
d'enfants par classe.
Il est urgent de remettre l'école
au milieu du village et du
quartier.
Etes-vous prêt à un moratoire pour
suspendre immédiatement cette
colère en 2023?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Monsieur le député,
le contexte démographique que
j'évoquais précédemment n'a pas
changé depuis une heure.
Nous avons -500 000 élèves
dans l'espace du quinquennat.
Dans votre département de
l'Allier, nous aurons -562 élèves
à la rentrée 2023.
Des modifications de la carte
scolaire sont donc prévues, et
elles sont discutées actuellement
avec les élus, y compris avec les
parlementaires.
Vous avez été reçu, je crois, par
la directrice académique.
En tenant compte de cela, nous
faisons de telle sorte aussi que
le taux d'encadrement s'améliore.
En d'autres termes, le ratio entre
professeurs et élèves
s'améliore, y compris dans votre
département de l'Allier, pour le
premier degré.
Des ajustements vont être encore
opérés d'ici au mois de juin, et
également au mois d'août, quelques
jours avant la rentrée scolaire.
Ces ajustements feront que le
schéma qui est présenté n'est pas
encore définitif.
Je vais regarder les situations
les plus problématiques, y compris
dans les départements ruraux,
comme le vôtre, avec une attention
particulière pour les situations
d'éloignement.
Le gouvernement est attentif aux
situations rurales.
Vous n'avez pas le monopole de ces
situations.
Nous y sommes aussi attentifs que
vous.
Nous fermons des classes en tenant
compte de la baisse des effectifs
scolaires, mais nous le faisons
avec discernement et en
collaboration avec les élus
locaux, avec qui j'échange de
manière très régulière, je peux
vous le garantir.
- Yannick Monnet: Pour les élus
locaux, le compte n'y est pas.
Quand on veut faire un
enseignement de qualité, on ne
gère pas l'école avec des chiffres
et des ratios.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Nicolas Thierry.
- Nicolas Thierry: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Le 30 janvier dernier, un
céréalier a été violemment
agressé.
Il a été ligoté, frappé et attaché
à son véhicule.
Il est un symbole.
Il a fait condamner Monsanto, le
géant des pesticides, après des
années de combat judiciaire.
Il mérite le respect de la
représentation nationale.
Nul ne peut cautionner les
agissements de ses agresseurs.
Ses agresseurs auraient prononcé
ces mots: "On en a marre de
t'entendre à la télé".
Leur objectif est de faire régner
le silence par la terreur.
Ce céréalier a été martyrisé
encore et toujours pour avoir osé
dire tout haut une vérité qui
dérange les lobbys
agro-industriels.
Un jour viendra où le monde se
libérera de cette emprise.
Ce jour-là, nous nous souviendrons
de Paul François et de son
courage.
Ma question est double.
Le combat de Paul François est
connu depuis longtemps.
Quels sont les moyens engagés par
le ministère de l'Intérieur pour
assurer sa sécurité?
Au-delà, comment assurer la
sécurité des lanceurs d'alerte?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au ministre de l'Agriculture.
- Marc Fesneau: Dans la continuité
de la réponse formulée par Gérald
Darmanin, je voudrais dire que
nous partageons votre indignation.
Nous avons besoin de nous mettre
d'accord sur l'idée que nous
dénonçons toutes les violences.
Gérald Darmanin a également
indiqué que la police s'était
emparée de cette affaire, qui est
très grave.
La justice est saisie.
Comme pour toutes les enquêtes et
tous les faits de violence, il n'y
a pas de tri.
Pour lui comme pour les autres, la
diligence sera faite.
Personne ne doit être intimidé ou
violenté en raison de ses
opinions.
Je pense à tous ceux qui sont
violentés en raison de leur
activité, notamment dans le monde
agricole.
J'entends bien défendre l'ensemble
des agriculteurs qui sont victimes
de violence verbale, de violence
violence physique.
La police et la justice seront au
rendez-vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Nicolas Thierry: Merci pour
votre réponse.
J'insiste sur la gravité de ce
qu'a vécu Paul François.
Au-delà de l'épreuve personnelle,
ce qui se joue, c'est la
possibilité pour des milliers de
militants de pouvoir lutter pour
le bien commun en toute sécurité.
C'est votre responsabilité de
pouvoir garantir cela.
- Marc Fesneau: C'est notre
responsabilité et c'est ce que
nous faisons pour toutes les
personnes qui sont menacées, y
compris les parlementaires ou les
représentants syndicaux.
Il n'y a pas de démocratie si une
violence se construit en
permanence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Angélique Ranc pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Angélique Ranc: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale.
Une nouvelle fois, le mois de
février ouvre la saison du
remaniement des cartes scolaires,
entraînant la fermeture de postes.
C'est une source d'inquiétude pour
les familles et un enjeu vital
pour nos communes, surtout quand
les effectifs sont stables.
Au sein même de mon département,
les élus de nos communes sont
contraints depuis des années à
proposer des solutions de
regroupement, afin de permettre de
fermer des écoles.
C'est ainsi que dans notre vallée,
une école va fermer malgré des
investissements communaux massifs.
Les fermetures de classes tendent
à se généraliser depuis des
années.
L'avenir de la ruralité passe par
les écoles et les enfants.
Je rappelle qu'en 2017, le
président affirmait que les
territoires ruraux "ne pouvaient
plus être la variable d'ajustement
de l'économie".
Sans surprise, le président Macron
ne considère pas la ruralité dans
ses choix politiques.
L'enseignement des fondamentaux
est en perdition.
Le niveau des élèves n'a jamais
été aussi faible, notamment en
mathématiques et en français.
Ce n'est pas en éloignant les
enfants de leur école que cela va
s'améliorer.
Ma question est simple.
Nos villages sont aussi des zones
prioritaires, alors allez-vous
enfin redonner des moyens pour que
les enfants nés dans les petits
villages puissent bénéficier de la
même qualité d'enseignement que
les enfants nés à Paris?
Les zones rurales sont les grandes
oubliées de votre gouvernement qui
ne pense qu'aux métropoles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Le contexte démographique que
j'évoquais précédemment n'a
toujours pas changé depuis
quelques minutes.
Dans votre département, ce sont
environ 300 élèves que l'on
comptera en moins à la rentrée
2023.
J'ai eu beau téléphoner aux
institutions académiques de votre
département, il y a des
ajustements qui sont en cours.
Nous tenons compte
particulièrement des territoires
ruraux.
Nous y sommes attentifs dans le
cadre des regroupements
pédagogiques intercommunaux.
Il y a une volonté des élus locaux
de coopération afin de maintenir
des écoles de qualité dans les
territoires.
Nous allons mettre en place des
classes dédoublées dans les
territoires ruraux de votre
département lorsque les
indicateurs sociaux montrent une
fragilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
- Angélique Ranc: Monsieur le
ministre, ce sont 17.000 écoles
qui ont fermé en 40 ans.
Je vous signale qu'à ce rythme, ce
sont toutes nos campagnes qui vont
disparaître.
- Pap Ndiaye: Madame la députée,
les territoires ruraux font
l'objet d'une attention soutenue
dans le travail de la carte
scolaire.
Le nombre d'élèves par classe est
plus faible dans les territoires
ruraux que dans les territoires
urbains.
Je vous signale que nous sommes au
travail actuellement pour remanier
la carte scolaire et je vous
suggère de la regarder d'un peu
plus près.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Liliana Tanguy.
- Liliana Tanguy: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au
secrétaire d'Etat à la mer.
Monsieur le ministre, dans la
continuité des engagements du
président de la République pour
soutenir les pêcheurs français,
vous avez lancé un plan
d'accompagnement individuel à
destination des propriétaires de
bateaux de pêche qui sont
fragilisés par le Brexit.
Les pêcheurs de ces zones sont
concernés notamment dans les ports
du Sud Finistère.
Ce plan vise à accompagner les
pêcheurs, que le Brexit a
contraints à mettre à l'arrêt leur
bateau.
Il doit permettre à une nouvelle
génération de pêcheurs d'exercer
leur métier dans de bonnes
conditions.
De nombreux armateurs ont fait une
demande d'accompagnement.
Sur 150 dossiers déposés, 46 ont
déjà été retenus.
Ces chiffres sont importants.
Il y a le risque de mettre en
péril le secteur de la pêche
bretonne.
Tous les acteurs de la filière
sont inquiets.
Notamment au Guilvinec, premier
port artisanal de pêche en France.
Un emploi en mer représente quatre
emplois à terre.
Il y a donc un risque pour
l'emploi local qui est très
dépendant de la pêche, qui
constitue un pôle d'attractivité
très important.
Pouvez-vous nous faire le point
sur ce plan, suite aux conventions
de sortie de flotte, en
particulier en Bretagne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Hervé Berville.
- Hervé Berville: Comme vous le
savez, le Brexit a été un choc
pour la filière de la pêche.
30% du volume de la pêche
française était lié directement à
l'accès aux eaux
britanniques.
Un plan a donc été préparé dans un
certain nombre de pays européens.
A la demande de la Première
ministre, nous avons souhaité
avoir une logique différente avec
un plan d'accompagnement
individuel.
Nous allons mettre en place des
mesures concrètes.
Notre objectif est d'éviter que le
fait de ne pas pouvoir avoir accès
aux eaux britanniques fragilise
nos pêcheurs et entraîne un
effondrement de la filière pêche
en Bretagne et en Normandie.
Il y a donc une enveloppe dédiée à
ceux qui ont été impactés
directement.
Je pense que nous sommes dans le
bon équilibre.
Nous avons construit ce plan avec
les professionnels de la pêche,
avec les acteurs locaux.
Nous avons veillé à la
transparence sur la réattribution
des droits de pêche, à la
préservation des équilibres
régionaux et on va continuer les
investissements pour soutenir la
pêche locale.
Dans un certain nombre de pays,
aux Pays-Bas ou en Irlande, il y a
30% de la pêche qui est touchée.
En France, nous sommes à 3%.
Je pense aussi aux
Hauts-de-France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Nathalie
Oziol.
- Nathalie Oziol: Mes
chers collègues, je voudrais
commencer par adresser toutes nos
pensées aux 35.000 victimes du
terrible séisme qui a frappé la
Turquie et la Syrie, ainsi qu'à
leurs familles et leurs proches.
Par ailleurs, l'OMS compte
désormais environ 26 millions de
sinistrés, 5 millions en situation
de grande vulnérabilité.
Le gouvernement français a
rapidement dépêché des personnels
de santé et des moyens matériels.
Cette réactivité rappelle
l'immense compétence du centre de
crise et de soutien du ministère
des Affaires étrangères dont tous
les moyens et toutes les
prérogatives doivent être
maintenus.
La France a un devoir d'humanité.
D'abord, de geler les expulsions
vers la Syrie et la Turquie dans
ce contexte exceptionnel.
De plus, nous devons leur
permettre un rapprochement avec
leurs familles habitant en France.
Certaines personnes ont tout
perdu.
Comme à chaque catastrophe, les
conditions d'hygiène font craindre
des épidémies.
Le gouvernement allemand a pris
une décision qui doit nous
inspirer.
Il a annoncé qu'il allait
faciliter l'octroi de visas de
trois mois pour les survivants de
la catastrophe, notamment dans le
cadre des rapprochements
familiaux.
L'Allemagne abrite la première
communauté turque en Europe, la
France abrite la deuxième.
Allez-vous simplifier les
formalités administratives pour
aider les Turcs et les Syriens qui
ont besoin d'être avec leurs
familles?
Comment allez-vous aider les plus
vulnérables, c'est-à-dire les
enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Le ministre
de l'Intérieur me prie de répondre
sur cette question qui est une
compétence partagée entre nos deux
ministères.
Sur l'octroi des visas d'urgence,
nos efforts vont se décliner de la
façon suivante, en fonction des
situations.
En premier lieu, nous allons faire
en sorte que les étrangers qui
sont actuellement en Turquie et en
Syrie et qui sont bénéficiaires
d'un titre de séjour en France
soient accompagnés pour accélérer
leur retour dans notre pays.
Ensuite, s'agissant des familles
de personnes étrangères séjournant
régulièrement en France, cela
appelle une évaluation conjointe
entre le ministère des Affaires
étrangères et le ministère de
l'Intérieur.
Face à un tel drame, la mise en
place de dispositifs ad hoc est
possible.
Cela requiert toutefois au
préalable d'un examen attentif
afin de pouvoir garantir un
accueil dans des circonstances
sécurisées pour notre territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roger Vicot pour le
groupe socialiste.
- Roger Vicot: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé.
Selon une étude publiée hier, la
hausse du nombre de personnes
souffrant de troubles dépressifs
dans notre pays est sans précédent
depuis 2017.
Cette hausse est inquiétante et
elle est majeure chez les jeunes
adultes.
La population étudiante déprimée a
doublé et elle atteint aujourd'hui
près de 20%.
Aussi, on note 58% d'augmentation
des passages aux urgences chez les
11-17 ans pour des troubles
suicidaires.
Les raisons sont multiples.
Le budget consacré à la santé
mentale en France avoisine les 110
milliards d'euros.
Sur cette somme, seulement 1,5
milliard d'euros est consacré à la
pédopsychiatrie.
Nous sommes loin des moyens
nécessaires pour faire face à la
situation.
Les délais d'attente peuvent aller
jusqu'à 2 ans.
C'est tout simplement inacceptable
pour des adolescents souffrant de
graves troubles.
Un exemple, monsieur le ministre.
Un des centres de la métropole
lilloise a vu
7 pédopsychiatres quitter leur
poste ces derniers mois.
La direction refuse de les
remplacer, sous le prétexte que ce
serait contre-productif.
C'est dire l'importance d'une
politique qui puisse véritablement
anticiper ces phénomènes pour que
nous n'ayons pas à les subir
collectivement.
Cela dit l'urgence d'adapter les
moyens dérisoires qui font face à
des besoins immenses.
Qu'envisagez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député, bien entendu, nous
partageons votre préoccupation sur
la santé mentale de nos jeunes
concitoyens.
Nous sommes particulièrement
attentifs à la situation et nous
regardons de façon très fine
l'étude dont vous parlez.
Nous constatons, dans les suites
de cette crise Covid, une
explosion des suicidés et des
tentatives de suicide chez les
jeunes filles, sans pour autant
que l'explication soit si simple.
Vous demandez ce que nous faisons.
Nous continuons à agir sur les
structures en place et en
continuant à les développer, comme
par exemple les maisons des
adolescents dans les départements.
J'ai pu également constater des
structures qui se déplacent, ainsi
que l'augmentation de l'activité
autour du numéro vert.
Si on considère le reste des
dispositifs, il y a plus de
300.000 consultations qui ont été
faites.
Nous continuons ce déploiement.
Enfin, les assises de la santé de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent sont
en cours et nous rendrons leurs
conclusions au printemps.
Un chapitre est entièrement dédié
à la santé mentale des enfants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Joëlle Mélin pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Joëlle Mélin: "Le mal existe",
criait Voltaire dans son poème sur
le désastre de Lisbonne.
Aujourd'hui, ce mal a touché la
Turquie et la Syrie.
Les aides humanitaires et les
moyens humains affluent en Turquie
et montrent une formidable
solidarité internationale.
Concernant la Syrie, Emmanuel
Macron a déclaré que cette
circonstance malheureuse pourrait
aider à la normalisation des
relations avec ce pays.
Derrière la communication, cette
promesse d'un retour à la
diplomatie par l'action
humanitaire résonne comme un
nouvel espoir de paix durable.
Après la guerre civile, ce pays
affronte sans aides occidentales
une nouvelle calamité.
La France vient d'augmenter son
aide financière d'urgence, mais
cet argent ne bénéficie qu'aux
populations syriennes sous
contrôle turc, alors même que 13,5
millions de Syriens ont besoin
d'aide humanitaire.
6 mois de trêve pour un pays qui
manque de tout, du savon aux
appareils de dialyse.
Nous ne devons pas laisser ces
populations abandonnées.
Elles n'auront alors que le choix
de l'exil et la Turquie pourra
faire du chantage migratoire.
Nous souhaitons aujourd'hui savoir
comment rendre notre aide
effective en Syrie et garantir le
retour rapide des ONG afin d'aider
les populations locales.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Madame la
députée, les séismes qui ont
frappé la Turquie et la Syrie sont
dévastateurs.
Leur terrible bilan humain est
encore provisoire.
Face à cette tragédie, la France
est au rendez-vous de la
solidarité.
S'agissant de la Turquie, notre
mobilisation a été immédiate, avec
l'envoi de 140 secouristes et
d'une équipe du centre de crise de
mon ministère qui est arrivé le
jour même dans les zones
sinistrées pour aider à la
recherche des survivants.
Je salue d'ailleurs la réactivité
des équipes du ministère de
l'Intérieur et de mon propre
ministère.
Au plan européen, ce sont près de
2200 secouristes qui sont
intervenus.
Nous avons pu également déployer
un hôpital de campagne pour
traiter plus de 100 patients
simultanément.
Nous sommes à notre connaissance
les seuls en Europe à pouvoir
envoyer une telle logistique aussi
rapidement.
Au nord de la Syrie, les pertes
humaines sont également
considérables.
Nous avons d'ores et déjà, malgré
les difficultés d'accès, débloqué
une aide d'urgence de 12 millions
d'euros, dont nous nous sommes
assurés qu'elle ira bien à la
population.
Cette aide ira aux populations
syriennes en Syrie.
Elle doit concerner tous les
Syriens affectés par cette
tragédie.
Ils en ont besoin.
Nous y travaillons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Frédéric Zgainski pour
le groupe démocrate.
- Frédéric Zgainski: Ma question
s'adresse à madame Olivia
Grégoire, ministre chargé des PME.
Madame la ministre, les formalités
administratives pèsent sur la vie
de nos PME.
Pour faciliter la création
d'entreprise, notre majorité a
décidé en 2019 de rassembler les
réseaux de création d'entreprise
en un seul guichet unique.
Ce guichet doit permettre à toutes
les entreprises de déclarer en
ligne toutes les formalités auprès
des différents organismes, que ce
soit les services fiscaux, sociaux
ou encore l'INSEE.
Tout doit se faire en ligne sur un
même site.
Cette dématérialisation, c'est une
bonne chose pour notre économie,
alors que les records de création
d'entreprise s'enchaînent.
Toutefois, de nombreux acteurs
nous font part de lourds
dysfonctionnements.
Des pages blanches,
l'impossibilité d'utiliser
certaines fonctionnalités...
De nombreux bugs contraignent les
acteurs à repousser leurs
démarches.
Il y a quelques semaines, vous
avez rouvert une autre plate-forme
pour aider aux formalités.
On peut également réaliser ses
démarches par la voie papier
auprès des greffes.
Cela nous renvoie des années en
arrière et ne nous permet pas de
pallier à ces défaillances.
Que comptez-vous faire, madame la
ministre, pour rétablir dans les
meilleurs délais un service
fiable?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Monsieur le
député, vous l'avez dit, donc je
me permets de le répéter, notre
réforme du guichet unique est
ambitieuse.
Elle concerne énormément
d'acteurs.
Elle concerne les centres de
formalités des entreprises.
On est passé de plus de 50
formulaires papier à un seul
formulaire en ligne.
Elle vise 100% de
dématérialisation.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes à 30%.
La marche est haute.
Nous avons encore clairement du
travail.
La satisfaction des utilisateurs
n'est pas au rendez-vous, et à
raison.
Je ne vais pas vous faire de
grands discours pour essayer de
peindre une réalité qui n'est pas
satisfaisante à date.
Je vais vous dire comment nous
allons chercher des solutions pour
que cela aille mieux et plus vite.
D'abord, je veux vous dire qu'en
matière de création, cela va
plutôt bien.
Nous sommes à 133.000 créations
gérées et enregistrées.
Nous sommes sur un rythme de
croisière qui reste quasiment
celui des années précédentes.
Nous avons encore du travail sur
les cessations d'activité.
C'est pourquoi nous avons donné la
possibilité de faire des
cessations d'activité par voie
papier, pour que les entreprises
puissent rapidement réaliser leurs
démarches.
Début mars, la plate-forme
fonctionnera.
Nos services sont jour et nuit à
la manoeuvre.
Il reste une quinzaine de jours.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance des
questions au gouvernement est
terminée.